[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
if you were registered to vote in the
United States your personal information
has almost definitely just been leaked
it was reported yesterday that the
personal data of a hundred and ninety
eight million American voters has been
compromised
that is roughly how many people are
registered to vote in the United States
the information covers about 61% of the
u.s. population this is almost every
voter and this was the largest known
leak of voter records in history but
hold on a second that Hillary Clinton
email server something something should
be more relevant than a republican data
analytics firm called deep root
analytics leaking this information and
leaked is leaked may not even be the
right word here because basically they
were storing all this data this
republican analytics firm they were
storing all this data of everyone's
voter information on an unsecured server
doesn't exactly sound responsible to me
pat when it didn't even need to be
hacked it was basically stored there
available to someone who knew what they
were looking for yeah and after the DNC
and the d-triple-c were hacked there was
a lot of people who said that the onus
was really on them that's right because
they didn't do enough to secure their
servers I guess you know this can happen
to any private organization right wing
wrongs included so it would seem and the
information in the database includes
name date of birth home address phone
number ethnicity religion occupation
elections that you voted in information
about who you would be likely to vote
for stances on particular issues maybe
from survey data or elsewhere really
just a ton of information and analytics
everything except for who you voted for
since that is not public information
where do they get this information well
it comes from a range of data sources
everything from donor history during
elections to magazine subscriptions to
other consumer behavior that is
available in databases companies you do
business with sell this information and
to be clear this is not by and large
confidential information it's arguably
sensitive
altogether it really paints a pretty
specific picture of who you are but a
lot of this can be compiled by anybody
if you spend enough time like for
example in New York in North Carolina
there's a website where you can really
just look up voter registrations and
that can start to put a picture together
then you can cross-reference that with
the dresses and go the geographical
profile you can use social media and
what's publicly available to build a
social profile etc etc and that is
exactly what this Republican analytics
firm deep root did now Alex laundry
who's a co-founder of the company has
put out a statement where he says in
part deep root analytics has become
aware that a large that that a number of
files within our online storage system
were accessed without our knowledge
since this event has come to our
attention we have updated the access
settings and put protocols in place to
prevent further access well that's great
now that every voter peeve every voters
information almost has leaked or been
accessed now they're going to take it
really seriously and aside from the
disturbing nature of a leak like this
many people are probably hearing me talk
about this Pat and didn't even realize
that databases databases like this even
exist but they do Democrats and
Republicans work with the data firms and
market researchers and analytics
providers to use big data to target
voters if you find out about this how
could you possibly not be worried about
the attack on net neutrality the recent
Republican bill which will allow your
internet service provider to sell your
browsing history to advertisers
how could anyone even to begin with
think that that's an okay idea but
especially after you learn about the
existence of databases like this how
could you be okay with what Republicans
are opting to allow ISPs to do with our
data right and we've known this for a
long time that if you're registered to
vote that your information is out there
somewhere yes that's why around election
season some people get calls all the
time while other people's don't really
get calls but I think this would be a
goldmine for say private investigators
or advertisers looking to appeal to a
specific audience no doubt about it this
is
exactly the type of database that can be
used not only for political targeting
but it can also be used for a
manipulative technique to sell products
or to influence public opinion and we've
talked about the many ways in which big
data can be can be used to those ends
and this should make us significantly
more concerned about all of what we're
seeing regarding Internet privacy and
Internet freedom and particularly that
Republican law are now allowing your ISP
to sell your browsing history to
advertisers disaster absolute and total
disaster okay I told you last week
earlier this week that coinciding with
Dennis Rodman's latest visit to North
Korea we also saw the release of otto
warmbier otto warmbier is an american
student who was arrested in North Korea
for allegedly stealing a poster a
propaganda poster from a North Korean
hotel the North Korean government agreed
to release him basically within hours of
Dennis Rodman's arrival for his latest
trip to North Korea so far we are told
that that was mere coincidental merely
coincidental in terms of the timing we
learned upon otto warmbier x' release
that he had been in a coma in North
Korea dating all the way back to March
of 2016 or about 15 months and we
learned over the last few hours that
otto warmbier has died now back in the
United States in Ohio near his family
this is just a horrible story the North
Korean government claimed he suffered
food poisoning had botulism lost
consciousness after being given a
sleeping pill unfortunately doctors here
in the u.s. found no evidence whatsoever
of botulism having been in his system to
the extent that that's possible to do
retro actively on at the same time they
found no evidence of physical abuse in
so far as there was not evidence of
healed fractures for example you
wouldn't necessarily be able to find
evidence of all kinds of physical abuse
at this point but again unclear and now
indeed he has passed away here in the
United States and this more or less
confirms the horrible reality of what we
assumed
North Korea was doing which is the
Dennis Rodman thing aside the timing of
that aside
they basically realized that this was
someone that was quickly deteriorating
and they did not want him dying on North
Korean soil it really is a tragedy and
rare credit to Donald Trump here for
showing some reserve and responding to
this yeah because he said you know it's
great that auto was able to go home to
his family for his final days and you
know we'll find a way to handle North
Korea really no president has been able
to do that especially because they have
nuclear weapons right in striking
distance to Seoul but it's just the
latest chapter although you so yes Trump
did seem to show some degree of
restraint but at the same time he also
slammed Obama saying hey otto warmbier
has been in North Korea since Barack
Obama was president and he didn't do
enough to get him out blah blah blah of
course this ignores the fact that there
are other Americans still in North Korea
who have been there for a while why
hasn't Trump gotten them out if he's the
great savior of people who get stuck in
North Korea and undoubtedly and this is
too bad but I'm sure in the future more
Americans will be held captive and we'll
go in while he's president well that's
what I wanted to ask you about which is
at this point would you go to North
Korea it's so to backtrack a little bit
otto warmbier was in North Korea with a
Chinese based company called young
pioneer tours that company as a result
of this incident has announced they will
no longer take American visitors to
North Korea I guess Chinese visitors to
North Korea are not as at risk of this
type of propagandistic detainment as
Americans are we interview a few years
ago this guy's filmmaker named Matt
doors and SiC who went to North Korea on
one of these tours did a great
documentary vice has been there we've
seen a number of these documentaries the
truth is every time you go into North
Korea particularly to record
surreptitiously audio or video you're
taking a major risk and Americans are at
risk we have other inch of instances of
Americans of more you know high-profile
incidents like these that have taken
place would you go to North Korea I
would only go to the joint security area
which is that room along the 38th
parallel that's shared by both the North
and South Koreans but you then join the
South node enter from the South I think
go to the north
out of the room but that would be about
it for me yeah so basically your answer
is no yes I would love to go I mean it
would be fascinating but honestly I
would wonder given my track record of
years of year and years of criticizing
North Korea would they be aware of my
views would they conspire to detain me
after approving me for a visa I think I
would probably be at risk I mean most of
the people there wouldn't be able to
look up the videos on the Internet no
but I'm but presumably Kim Jong Un's
would be able to write yeah I think I
probably wouldn't go although I would I
would love to and I think it would be
endlessly fascinating I think for my own
safe safety it would be a bad idea to go
and same question kind of comes up given
my long track record of comments about
Russia like would it even be safe to go
to Russia I would certainly be what's
considered a political dissident there
we know how they treat them would they
would would I end up accidentally
stabbing myself in the back ten times or
something like that who knows
last week we did this story about megyn
kelly former fox news reporter megan
kelly choosing on her second episode of
her new NBC news network show choosing
to interview conspiracy theorists Alex
Jones and I said very clearly last week
I have no problem with people
interviewing Alex Jones I don't believe
in no platforming him however given all
the hubbub and the big deal that was
made about megyn kelly the great megyn
kelly leaving fox news and she's going
to have this tremendous show she gets an
interview with Vladimir Putin and it's
all extraordinary and fantastic and then
Episode two of the show she interviews
Alex Jones so I said I just thought he
wasn't worthy of the platform now we did
a a non-scientific poll at david
pakman.com I am NOT presenting this as a
perfectly sampled scientific poll of all
Americans it's merely a representative
view of people in our audience who chose
to vote saying what's your opinion of
megyn kelly decision to interview Alex
Jones on her new Network show 49% of our
audience agrees with megyn kelly
decision to interview Alex Jones
interesting 46 percent of our audience
disagrees with the decision
some of whom because they believe Alex
Jones just isn't notable enough for that
platform some people in our audience
saying they don't agree with megyn kelly
decision to interview Alex Jones because
he is offensive now what I think is the
most relevant thing we learned about
this interview is that in the end people
weren't that interested in it because it
got shockingly low ratings I ended up
not watching it at all I had other
things to do and it wasn't important
enough for me to turn it on and watch it
I've not watched it after the fact so
that actually is the most interesting
thing which was the news of the
interview generated controversy and Alex
Jones leaking his recorded phone calls
with megyn kelly during the
pre-production process got some
attention but in the end the ratings for
this interview were low and I think that
innocent
I am vindicated in that he's just not
worthy of the platform and people didn't
really care or I wonder if people were
protesting because they disagreed with
Megan Kelly's choice to interview him I
mean I think it was totally fine I think
he is relevant at this point because I
mean his YouTube channel has over a
billion views he has a big talk radio
audience as well and while he says
offensive things it's not as if he's
doing the offensive actions himself like
you know he denies the Sandy Hook
shooting right but he's not the Sandy
Hook shooter okay well Wow I mean if
we've ever found a silver lining that
requires more of a reagent hey Alex
Jones didn't do Sandy Hook I guess
you're right I mean that's Joe he didn't
do Sandy Hook and that I would
definitely be different I like that
approach but it wasn't notable enough
for you to watch it right no I'm you
know yeah thank you supporting the
Vladimir Putin interview either okay
that's fair anyway so our audience
roughly split although for different
reasons between people who believe it
was a good idea and people who believe
it was not our new poll at david
pakman.com I encourage you to vote now
will Donald Trump fire assistant
attorney general rod Rosenstein that is
the current poll question at david
pakman.com you can vote there send me
your thoughts about it I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and of course you can follow
the show on twitter at david pakman show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Applause]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is david hi mo would david thank you so
much for being a david pakman show
member we're mostly funded by our
audience through the membership program
we also have a great list of members
only benefits including the daily
world-famous bonus show you can sign up
and get instant access at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code is available to you for big savings
it is I voted 17 and you can also make a
contribution via patreon for as little
as one dollar per month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show Pat we are
starting to see sort of the Russian
matryoshka doll equivalent of people
lawyering up now Donald Trump's lawyer
has lawyer duck the investigation into
Donald Trump and Russia is clearly
getting closer and closer to more and
more Donald Trump associates previously
I told you that Donald Trump personally
lawyered up at the recommendation of his
lawyer Michael Cohen so Michael Cohen
went to Donald Trump and said you should
get a lawyer specifically for the Russia
stuff so Donald Trump hired mark caso
it's to represent him personally in the
Trump Russia thing we now know that
Trump is personally under investigation
by special prosecutor Robert Muller now
Donald Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen has
lawyered up himself and recall that
Michael Cohen plays in the entire
Russian blackmail dossier Michael Cohen
is one of the people supposedly involved
in hand-delivering that plan related to
the easing of Russian sanctions
involving disgraced former national
security adviser Michael Flynn so he has
hired a lawyer as it appears to be
closing in on him as well he will be
represented by Washington DC attorney
Stephen Ryan and a source told NBC's
Katie tour that Michael Cohen will
testify before the House Intelligence
Committee
on September 5th now you might say wow
that's that's really a long time from
now
apparently the testimony was delayed due
to quote scheduling and logistics but it
is not just Michael Cohen who is luring
up Vice President Mike Pence is also
lowering up and that is yet another
indication that this is closing in he's
hired personal representation Richard :
an attorney who previously served as US
attorney in the Eastern District of
Virginia is representing vice president
Mike Pence on everything related to the
two congressional investigations as well
as Robert molars special prosecutor
investigation this is not good everybody
seems to have to lawyer up at this point
well first off it would make sense that
Michael Cohen would want to lawyer up
because he's been Donald Trump's
personal lawyer for ten years now yeah
it's not only he's just signed on since
the Russia probe began George and if you
look at the Christopher Steele dossier
that dossier alleges that he met with
Russian agents in Prague tour to discuss
the potential cover-up of the hacks yes
so he's heavily involved and of course
he denied having ever gone to Prague
presetting then walked the land in
Prague then royal e-type answer yeah
when we looked at the letter of that he
said he never walked the land of Prague
which means hey if he was in an airport
without having cleared customs for
example was he technically walking the
land in Prague not really the judge just
one hypothetical right but what's the
what's the silver lining here I'm now
doing the Pat Forde thing where I'm
trying to find silver linings trump is
finally creating work because there's a
bunch of lawyers now that are doing
really well representing different
people associated with Trump with
relation to the Trump Russia situation
Trump's lawyer has a lawyer
it's lawyers all the way down a
reference to the unmoved mover paradox
look that up it's interesting it Turtles
all the way down is the phrase as it
originally is but I think a better
analogy pad if you'll allow me is since
we're dealing with Russia
these are those Russian matryoshka dolls
successively smaller and smaller dolls
nested within each other its successive
representation by lawyers nested within
each other is what we're seeing here I
like that and then Mike
Harrison would be to house of cards
because it would make sense that Mike
Pence would want to lawyer up as well
because if Trump was to be impeached
then he would have to keep his own name
clear to assume the presidency that's
what I'm most interested in which is
Mike Pence's involvement what did he
know and when he was after all the head
of the transition team he ignored
multiple warnings about Michael Flynn he
generally lies a lot like most of the
people associated with Donald Trump I
wouldn't be shocked if Mike Pence turns
his back on Trump if it all starts
closing in on him I have no idea what
was going on I was brought in as a
running mate they kept me out of the
loop I didn't know what was happening
blah blah blah and by the way another
lawyer speaking of Russian dolls Mark
Kassovitz has told some White House
personnel they don't need to hire their
own lawyers and now he is potentially in
trouble with multiple State Bar
Association's for that recommendation
mark Kassovitz Trump's personal lawyer
facing ethics complaints because he told
White House staffers don't worry you
don't need to hire lawyers this is
really building into a show of
incompetence building on arrogance and
pomposity sprinkled with delusions of
grandeur and hypocrisy
well I'm sure being the president and
vice president Trump and pence will be
able to get the best lawyers in the
country right the cream of the crop
let's dig into that now that is the next
thing I want to talk about in the midst
of the Russia scandal Donald Trump has
hired yet another lawyer
a guy named Jay Sekulow and it was quite
an unusual choice and things with Jay
Sekulow are already really not going
well I saw an interview with him and
realized who he was because I actually
interviewed Jay Sekulow son Jordan
Sekulow on the program years ago I think
it was back in 2010 and we learned last
week from five different sources that as
a result presumably of now being under
investigation by FBI special prosecutor
Robert Muller
Donald Trump has multiple lawyers
advising him Jay Sekulow had the very
difficult task of going on Fox News
really good he went on a number of these
Sunday morning channels and having to
sort of try to argue that there's
nothing to see here with Donald Trump
being per
simile under investigation while trying
not to lie because again even Donald
Trump himself went on Twitter and said
yeah I am under investigation and that
very strange tweet so Jay Sekulow shows
up he's got no experience in this type
of thing and he's basically a TV lawyer
he's got a radio show he's one of these
messianic Christians known as Jews for
Jesus sometimes he was born into a
Jewish family converted to Christianity
but considers himself a Messianic Jew
and these are some of the most extreme
people out there religiously and he has
worked from a legal perspective trying
to get legalized death penalty for gays
in Africa something Scott lively a guy a
pastor here from Massachusetts has
worked on we're talking about one of the
most extreme religious nuts out there in
Jay Sekulow
and he was a former Fox News legal
pundit right was it with Trump and these
Fox News lawyers keep watching he don't
even Paul attano was on his shortlist
for the Supreme Court
that's right Trump watches Fox News and
goes out that that's somebody that I
should hire to help me out here okay so
let's skip to the meat of this which is
Jay Sekulow gets interviewed on Fox News
Sunday by Chris Wallace and he's
simultaneously within within seconds
both says that Trump is under
investigation and Trump is not under
investigation and it is everything that
you would imagine it to be take a listen
to this under investigation now do you
well no one's notified us that he is so
I can't read people's minds but I can
tell you this we've not been notified
that there's an investigation of the
President of the United States and now
he's being investigated by the
Department of Justice because the
special counsel under the special
counsel regulations report still to the
Department of Justice not an Independent
Counsel so he's being investigated used
that he is being investigated and it's
not really any weight on another Jay and
it's not very it's not just being and so
I do not appreciate you putting words in
my mouth when I've been crystal clear
that the president is not and has not
been under investigation I don't think I
could be any clearer than that well you
don't know that he's not under
investigation again sir I mean you know
I cannot read them up you're right Chris
I can't read the mind okay so we're in
agreement you don't know everything
you don't know what I wrote about okay
so he says Trump is not under
investigation then he says yeah he's
under investigation by these specific
people and then he says I've been
crystal clear here Chris now he is not
under investigation this is why nobody
wants to be Trump's lawyer because you
have to deal with Trump tweeting
offhandedly what by mere chance seems to
be the truth which is he is under
investigation and then he has to show up
and try to deny that he's under
investigation and it's also obvious why
Trump had to resort to a lawyer like
seculow because respectable law firm
said he might not pay us and he
definitely won't listen to us so we're
not taking the case and really in that
position seculow should have just said I
misspoke I didn't mean to say that Trump
was under investigation yeah that
wouldn't have looked too pretty but it
would have been a lot better than this
this is a disaster there's not an
absolute is that this it just just say
it say you misspoke say you're not
commenting right now say it's not in the
interests of the President to talk about
a possible ongoing that almost anything
would be better than in a 15-second span
saying both that Trump is not and is
under investigation and personally I
look forward to Jay Sekulow hiring an
attorney that's really what I'm waiting
for at this point who is he going to get
to represent him in this entire thing
also credit to chris wallace for pushing
him back fine oh yeah i mean he is a Fox
News guy of cholesterol actually been
given the Russia investigation some
ample cover yeah he is actually somebody
that you could at least expect some
semblance of serious questions from hey
let's talk about our favorite Bush
dwelling press secretary Sean Spicer -
absolutely
no one's surprise White House press
secretary Sean Spicer is on his way out
as White House press secretary this is
being framed as both a promotion for
Sean Spicer and a some kind of complex
strategic decision a realignment of
roles blah blah blah
this is Spicer being pushed out because
he's terrible at his job and the
background is that yesterday we learned
that the latest press briefing from the
White House Sean Spicer had already
kicked out cameras from some of these
press briefings yesterday he also didn't
allow audio recording of the press
briefing it's a press briefing used
to report about the White House's
position on things very important things
to quote Donald Trump what's the point
if nobody can record audio or video of
it so we knew early in the day yesterday
that something wasn't looking good and
now we have learned from White House
officials in a statement yesterday that
they have quote sought input from many
people as they look to expand the
communications operation as he did in
the beginning Sean Spicer is managing
both the communications and press office
he will continue to fill the role of
communications director that is a role
that has been empty since the end of May
after the person in that role Mike
dubbed ki rasoi
he will not be doing the press briefings
this is a firing in all but name you
don't move someone out of that role it
is an important position it is a very
visible position you don't move someone
out of that role if they are doing a
good job you find someone else to run
the communications department and the
technicality that they're using pat is
hey you know what communications
director is technically a higher
position than press secretary which is
true but you don't get rid of your
public spokesperson if they're doing a
good job I wonder why this is happening
now though because Sean Spicer has been
disgracing himself on national TV for a
long time and stay one and of course
Trump kept them around because the guy
gets good ratings but I think it really
comes down to death by a thousand cuts
it's not there's no coup de Gras moment
you know there's no wind right there's
no possible wind because on day one
Spicer had to go out there and defend
the indefensible which was to argue that
indeed Donald Trump did have the record
inauguration crowd that he claimed to
have and what I what I'm wondering is
does the Trump administration think that
Spicer is the problem
Spicer is a symptom it's donald trump
who made on day one the assertion that
he had record inauguration turnout and
who on day one directed his press
secretary to go out and claim that he
had a record inauguration crowd Spicer
was a symptom of the problem it could
have been anybody going out there to
make that case and it would have been a
disaster but I think it's fair to say
that Spicer didn't help mitigate any of
those problems and I think maybe we
should come up with a montage of the top
five spiciest
Sean Spicer moment we would need to go
more than five yeah I think capped off
by the inauguration crowd size Fiasco
yeah and Hitler's use of chemical
weapons
those would definitely be included there
but I think we would probably need it to
be like the top 15 to even do justice to
the last few months Laura Ingraham
right-wing radio host reportedly being
considered for the position apparently
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the deputy press
secretary not being considered for the
position which is interesting because
reportedly Donald Trump has liked the
job that she has done when filling in
for Sean Spicer so we will see but yet
another one
spices us lots of discussion about this
on our reddit discussion forum which you
can drawing at david patten.com slash
read the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
okay last week I announced that we would
be giving away six free memberships for
one year and the context was that this
guy who goes by the the handle gr who
regularly participates in our YouTube
live streams he regularly sent comments
that are basically what we've called
incoherent rants now they're not hatred
mail they are
I guess generally positive to the extent
that I have any clue at all what it is
that's being said he offered to sponsor
six memberships for a year and what we
decided was that we would basically open
up the email inbox to people who want to
submit their own rant in the style of GR
and that we would decide on the best six
of them and give away six free
memberships okay so reminder once again
these are not hatred mail here are two
example incoherent rants from gr and
I'll read these as best I can and again
it's tough for me to even really
understand them here's the first one
pack D Z take it from the top
bring us to the progressive pastures of
green emerald utopia science fiction us
to a trump with swirled love gr okay
that's one example again not hatred mail
but mostly unintelligible here's another
one maybe more representative of a
typical gr rant
it's time bonus show or Co me flow don't
own up to we who call that session
testimony just a session full of old
baloney
Spanky like Trump the nasty face so
orange he matched the prison jammies
okay that's how we set it up pat now I
didn't know exactly what to expect
we received dozens of submissions from
people who decided I would say probably
in the in the three in the triple digits
like over a hundred submissions and I've
narrowed it down to these six winners
okay
now as always people will hear this and
they'll say mine was better than one of
those many factors were taken into
consideration a complex algorithm was
used to determine who the winners were
in both vocabulary pacing length context
subject matter yeah all of those things
were taken into consideration so here
are the six winners who are getting a
free david pakman show membership
courtesy of incoherent ranter gr first
and foremost is Roberto Katella who
wrote in saying Trump is first among
buffoons
Spicer's press briefing a bunch of
balloons bannon's got less friends than
Saturn's got moons tired of American
politics should be the title of world
headlines now even the French can
ridicule us without feeling guilty while
innocent Saudi go around policing
naughty Qatari and Yemen rebels luckily
enough TPP is gone so at last Mexico and
Canada can go after each other without
pretending we don't exist because we
don't this was a nice balance between
timely political subject matter
combined with endless run-on sentences
and bizarre sentence structure that is
one of our winners of a free membership
yeah I feel like it's when you're in
high school and you have to read a poem
and really provide some sort of literary
analysis yeah through with a highlighter
and a few pens to really understand the
author's intent a few pens would have
liked to have been a fly on the wall in
Pat's English class see what's going on
in there okay next winner Christian joy
Zilla who said the dream wait now hold
on we skipped over one there about here
we go Christian Christian joy villa the
dream Pat us down with your gentle vegan
votes voice your Keurig filled fanny
packs coffe Fe the soul to feeling
everlasting Pat sessions we don't recall
Pat no cheesy the spices hidden so spice
up that world in which all existence
dreams Trump golf forbidden so this one
a vegan producer Pat themed incoherent
rant very very good
another good approach because obviously
you're going to win no doubt about it
absolutely Jonathan MacGyver is our
third winner who wrote Patriots
mentioned David's Jewish heritage like
they want a star on his chest he's an
honest media man though he hasn't drunk
the cob feffy like all the rest they
ain't got nothing to say about David and
Pat
and the bonus show is where it's at
clever clever to mention membership
benefits probably helped that is next
winner I mean he did misspelled hatreds
yes but is it okay our next winner is
Bernd cycler who wrote punch up to that
who's orange Hitler bro with that sick
coma coherence flow because he a dum-dum
Reid can no tax return revealed this
corrupt to the next cell then he feeling
that infrared magenta magma inhale like
the failing fake news Lion King scar
from burning ground progressive Phoenix
comes then Simba in Pride Rock America
from hyena trumpets a lot of imagery
from The Lion King and I like that that
was also an interesting approach this
would make some great slam poetry that's
the kind of thing you have to deliver in
front of a whole group of people oh yeah
absolutely and there should probably be
some musical accompaniment to that
alright our fifth winner is Erik Erik
with a Q when David was a little boy
growing up in the fields of
Worcestershire sauce he used to get so
mad when I would take the bull by the
horns because he wanted the candy corns
and all the king's horses and all the
king's men couldn't grab him by the
pretty sure everyone you know has been
using russian salad dressing on your
greens for a minute now hashtag
unprecedented okay so resident
right but well they did it in unlike as
in no precedent no precedent okay i hope
i think though that was a trump
reference exactly and also a
massachusetts reference the land of
Worcestershire sauce of course we're
talking about Worcester although I don't
know if Worcestershire sauce is actually
from Worcester Mass it's not right yeah
also in city in England I think - right
well of course absolutely alright and
finally the sixth and final recipient of
a free membership courtesy of incoherent
ranter gr is Jake oka sessions imploding
approval late approval rates lowering
due to boycott silencing the Afro man
David and sidekick Pat
nobody can silence Trump's
compliance face so jank look like a
rotten sweet potato he think there isn't
an alliance working in defiance but he
don't know use coupon code i've oted 17
for 40% off of your membership very very
good wrap up there referencing the
coupon code six winners thank you to gr
for providing us this opportunity in
sponsoring the six memberships we
already have our next membership
sponsorship lined up that's going to be
in July and it will be patriotism themed
around the 4th of July so this is a
really great thing and we can't thank gr
enough you can email in if you are one
of the six winners we will also email
you probably within the next 24 hours
okay real quick a viewer let's call him
Jimmy to protect his identity that's not
his real name but I want to protect his
identity because of where he works
Jimmy wrote in to tell us that at his
place of employment the New York State
Capitol building the David Pakman show
website is blocked but Alex Jones's
Infowars website is allowed at the New
York State Capitol building this is an
email i received from quote jimmy who
said hey david check it out you're
blocked at the new york state capitol i
like to listen to the show at work but
unfortunately the show has been blocked
by our IT department not sure why
youtube is available secular talk is
available even steven Crowder's web site
is available i heart radio was blocked
but not Sirius XM or Infowars not sure
what the standard could possibly be
thought it was an interesting thing to
point out thankfully i have unlimited
data so i can just listen on my cell and
he sent a picture also pointing out that
when trying to access david pakman.com
he gets a message saying that this
category is not allowed because it is
streaming media if the barometer is
streaming media web sites are blocked
how could you tube not be blocked what
what is a bigger streaming media website
then going on YouTube and streaming
endless gigabytes of high-definition
video but yet david pakman.com is
blocked
and I spoke to our analytics department
and they estimate that had we not been
blocked at the New York State Capitol
the channel would have had over had
overall maybe a billion two billion more
views I read the same thing yeah that's
merely because there's such a demand for
the david pakman show at the New York
State Capitol building that were it not
for that we would already have our
million subscriber plaque from YouTube
up on the wall instead of just a hundred
thousand subscriber plaque so yeah I
don't know what the logic is it's very
odd
I want to resist becoming conspiratorial
but I wonder if there is some political
motivation taking place in terms of what
websites are and aren't blocked at the
New York State Capitol building am I
going too far maybe Pat and waiting in
two waters where I live evidence I think
this is grounds for investigation at
least I mean we can't really jump to any
conclusions you know but I think it's
reason for concern I find it odd I find
it really odd that we're blocked because
we're screening media but YouTube's not
blocked but yet Infowars
and Steven Crowder's website are allowed
at the New York State Capitol
very very strength we'll take a break
maybe we'll find out more about that we
will come back and I have sort of some
good news about what's going on in the
fight for net neutrality the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
I talked to you already about this July
12th national day of action for net
neutrality in the US fewer issues right
now more important in terms of how many
other issues they relate to and impact
and inform and there's different
participating websites that are going to
put up prominent messages about the
FCC's plans to get rid of net neutrality
and it will tell you how to contact
Washington about the issue how to find
your representative etc Netflix used to
be a major player in the fight for net
neutrality during the Obama
administration lobbying activism etc and
a couple weeks ago when I told you about
this day of action I mentioned all of a
sudden Netflix is missing from the big
Internet companies that are on board
with this and Netflix's CEO Reed
Hastings is actually on record recently
as having said quote we think net
neutrality is incredibly important but
not narrowly important to us because we
are big enough to get the deals we want
so rightly people were saying Netflix is
too big for its britches all they care
about is making money they're big enough
to be part of the in rather than the out
but I am pleased to tell you that
Netflix finally has changed their mind
on this and made an announcement a few
days ago via Twitter saying quote
Netflix will never outgrow the fight for
net neutrality everyone deserves an open
Internet now this could be because
Netflix realized oh yeah we do care
about this but it also could be because
it was just bad press not to be a part
of it but either way this is good
Netflix is now fully planning to
participate on the July 12th day of
action to bring attention to what's
going on with net neutrality and a
Netflix spokesperson has put out a
statement now saying quote we support
strong net neutrality protections even
if we are less rat less risk because of
our popularity there are other major
there are other companies for whom this
is a bigger issue and we're joining this
day of action to ensure the next netflix
has a fair shot to go the distance
Amazon is involved reddit is involved
Kickstarter Vimeo Etsy Mozilla OkCupid
imager on and on and on
and we know that people are very
engaged in this topic I told you two
weeks ago that the FCC said it received
five million formal written comments on
the matter so I think that there's
definitely a PR and optics angle to
Netflix getting reinvent is good no
matter what right forgive my skepticism
here though but is it possible that
Netflix will join the site but not
really be on the front lines because if
net neutrality were to end then they
also kind of win and then they're trying
to have it both ways yeah I mean your
skepticism is logical given the fact
that you know it's 2017 earth and
everything that we know that has gone on
that has gotten us to where we are today
your skepticism makes sense I still
think the net impact is it is good to
have their name on this they are the
most popular video streaming service in
the US but the internet-based video
streaming industry as a whole really
needs net neutrality so if it's if it's
not Netflix they are right that the next
Netflix or some smaller version is that
major risk because of net neutrality
because without net neutrality cable
providers can prioritize cable TV in
ways that can deter people from saying
hey I'll cancel cable because the
Internet video streaming is just as good
that's the risk and that's why this is
so important so in the long run it's
great to have Netflix and involvement
they'll probably also benefit in the
long run I believe it would be way more
effective if these websites didn't work
on July 12 imagine if all of July 12th
from midnight to midnight you go to
Netflix and they have a big thing saying
we need net neutrality call your
representatives we are off in protest of
course a website like Amazon think about
how much money they would lose if they
were to do something like that it's sort
of never going to happen but that I
think is what would be most impactful
here right if Netflix was to join into
that protest then people would go
without entertainment for a day yeah
maybe if a site like Amazon or Google
shut down for a day whole companies
would have to close and that would have
some real financial implications but
maybe that's how you make an impact
right maybe if you say hey look at how
much money is connected to what we are
doing if all of a sudden you've got to
pay $5.99 to be able to stream without
buffering or what
right I mean it this is what we're
talking about I can't possibly overstate
the importance of this enough call your
lawmakers go to who is my representative
calm this sort of appears maybe Pat to
be an issue we're calling your lawmakers
might make a tiny bit of difference on a
lot of issues it's like yeah it's just
not changing campaign finance for
example but on net neutrality there have
actually been some pretty successful
public out cries and protests let's talk
about Cuba we have the newest
development in Donald Trump's ongoing
quest to undo anything good that former
President Barack Obama accomplished
you'll remember that two years ago
President Obama loosened up the travel
and trade restrictions between Cuba and
the US because let's face it the decades
and decades of fighting communism
through the Cuban embargo was mostly
just punishing average Cubans and a
potential American tourist and American
businesses Without Really defeating
communism through that embargo and it
made no sense to continue including the
fact that it was completely hypocritical
for the u.s. to maintain it so a
majority of Americans and about half of
Cuban Americans like what President
Obama did but Donald Trump is going to
be reversing many of those things very
complex things as Trump likes to say
that President Obama did here's a little
bit of video for you on my recent trip
overseas I said the United States is
adopting a principle Grille ISM rooted
in our values shared interests and
common sense I also said countries
should take greater responsibility for
creating stability in their own regions
it's hard to think of a policy that
makes less sense then the prior
administration's terrible and misguided
deal with a Castro regime
[Applause]
yeah I like how firm says it's hard to
think of a worse policy than what Obama
did with Cuba I thought the Paris
agreement was the worst policy according
to Donald Trump
I thought the Iran deal was the worst
policy according to Donald Trump in any
case Trump wants to make it more
difficult for Americans to travel to
Cuba for tourism he wants them more
closely monitor the purposes of people's
trips to the island nation Americans
will have to fill out forms when they
come back to the US explaining what they
did why they did it only things like
charitable and educational visits will
be allowed and those will be more
strictly enforced and Donald Trump plans
to make it illegal for American
companies to do business with companies
owned by the Cuban government that is
hilarious
because Trump explored and arguably
violated trade law when he explored
doing business in Cuba he ended up going
down there and not personally right but
sending sending representatives down
there to explore doing business there
they spent sixty eight thousand dollars
in 1998 to explore whether they wanted
to do business there they potentially
skirted the illegality by running the
money through some consulting agency or
something like that and from ultimately
decided not to do business in Cuba not
because it would have violated the
embargo but because he decided it wasn't
a good business opportunity so as always
with Trump it's bad policy wrapped in a
double standard served on a plate
alongside hypocrisy yet on the campaign
trail he was a lot more moderate on this
issue it seems that since he's taken
this Marco Rubio style approach which is
that we have to get everything and they
have to get nothing yeah make a deal
with them and you know that could
include having Cuba no longer punish
dissidents or you know open up their
their free press and all that stuff but
it's not like this thing can really be
renegotiated so easily now it can't and
Trump also as part of this wants to
prevent Cuban refugees from who reach us
Shores from having immigration
advantages which has been a longtime
policy of the US Trump talks about how
it's all about helping Cubans now of
course supposedly the entire embargo was
to help Cubans get out of communism but
that didn't exactly work
now it's all about helping Cubans how
are you helping Cubans by not giving
them those advantages in the immigration
system I'm not arguing for or against
those advantages but it can't really be
argued that you're helping Cubans by
getting rid of those advantages and
fundamentally this is about appeasing
Cuban Republicans right if you look at
the entire Latino electorate it is very
very liberal and I've spoken about my
family in Argentina you've basically got
the left side of the family and the very
left side of the family and that really
you're talking about intra left debates
in many Latin and South American
countries one of the few groups of
Latino voters that more regularly is
represented in the Republican Party is
Cuban Americans who oftentimes as a sort
of knee-jerk opposition to Cuban
communism decide to go Republican in the
US because that's what feels most
opposed to that that's who Trump is
pandering to with this and of course a
lot of Cuban Americans have settled in
Miami and in Florida at large and that's
a state that he would have to win if
he's going to secure re-election in 2020
it seems nuts to even be thinking about
Trump's reelection at this point but
it's no foregone conclusion that he
wouldn't be reelected he might be
impeached and/or resigned in shame or he
might end up serving eight years I mean
we really just have no idea at this
point and anything in between is
obviously possible as well
hey interesting voicemail today our
voicemail number is two one nine two
david p here's someone who thinks that
pat might be making a power play to take
over as host of the david pakman show
it's quite a theory take a listen to
this yeah they with your boy Patrick for
there he might just be superseding me on
your own show I just want to go warning
about that fact all right well you have
a good day there David thank you
appreciate that people used to suggest
this when Lewis was producer they would
say why can't you make Lewis the host of
the show that will it wouldn't really be
the David Pakman show anymore you know
it's no it's like a confusing thing but
I know what you're talking about wink
wink I know about the power play you're
talking
about that Pat is making to try hot on
apparently he's caught he knows what's
going on and I know that you've been
playing coy about it Pat but clearly
it's not fooling everybody because this
guy has picked up on it I mean some
people think that I would have the
ability to have a show of my own
I really don't possess those talents I
mean I'm much better over here pushing
my button chiming in every now and then
I can't do what you do pushing buttons
literally and figuratively I would say
thank you alright so anyway we will see
if Pat I'm going to do what I can I'm
going to try to stage a resurgence and
Frank Underwood type in a manner
reminiscent of Frank Underwood to try to
regain control of the David Pakman show
and we'll see if that succeeds we've got
a tremendous bonus show for you today
folks I mean it's it's the best trust
people are telling me this day in and
day out david packing.com slash
membership is how you sign up and get
instant access to that bonus show and i
look forward to speaking to you guys
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]